and I already know the Shad is real I
believe the Shad is real the evidence is
overwhelming that Imaging It's
Supernatural they did not have the
technology to leave that kind of image
right because that would require
technology unheard of in the first
century and they even say we don't even
have the technology duplicate it now
that Imaging was left by a blast of
light like a radiation right it is a Mir
because that's the light of Jesus the
Divine Light just just imprinted His
Image as a testimony that he's risen
he's alive yet with or without the
Shroud Jesus is alive but now let me
play Cameron bartuzi Cameron bartuzi
real quickly Cameron bartuzi I'm just G
to play the last minute right even here
it says I guess Michael NOS just came up
with one too here see it's all over the
news here's I haven't watched this I'm
seeing it right now here's Michael NOS
talking about it see the news just came
out today it's all real there it goes so
here it is Michael NOS about the Shroud
so what does he say a new study done on
the Shroud let me enlarge
it I know it's true it's a fact
overwhelming evidence shows it's from
the first century and that imaging has
to be a work of God I do believe is the
sh of Christ
I have no doubt about it all honest
studies will simply confirm what we
already know to be true a new study done
on the Shroud turn has found that the
purported bear cloth of Jesus is 2,000
years old rather than several hundred
years old this is scandalous even for
some religious people want religion to
be an abstract thing Jesus is leaving
the nations with no excuses what do I
believe is happening okay here's the
link for all of you what do I believe is
happening because I believe the Lord
Jesus is going to return sooner than
later and I'm not a prophet not I don't
know if it's 20 years so now 100 years
now but because the Lord is coming
sooner than later he's now unleashing a
flood of evidence massive overwhelming
evidence from science medicine history
archaeology right to give people
no excuse not to believe the god of the
Bible is true the Bible is historically
accurate God's word and Jesus is Alive
he is Lord and return physically and
bodly from near-death experiences to all
these modern phenomenon of bonafide
recorded miracles to the complexity of
the Universe on and on it goes because
Jesus does not want anyone to perish he
wants his creation to turn and live so
in his love he will then flood you with
evidence to leave you without excuse
this is why I believe God is now raising
up lines and luses and I pray on one of
them to obliterate demolish annihilate
all anti-trinitarian
theologies and anti-christian worldviews
annihilate them as you see what we're
doing Islam and Joe's Witnesses and
arings to bring them all to the true God
who loves them the true God revealing
Jesus Christ and to a scriptures ho
Bible okay Focus guys remember engage me
not one another this what I believe is
happening we're living in some exciting
time young men and women your generation
spoiled the massive amount of
evidences historically textually
archaeologically scientifically
medically and all these resources online
you only pay for internet you are
spoiled you should be Scholars and
theologians right
God is Almighty Christ is risen the Lord
is real he is reality all right so
that's that's Michael no so I haven't
seen that let me go now go to scientific
proof the shoud is authentic all right
I'm just gonna play the last minute
remember YouTube copyright law allows
for fair
use fair
use we can play clips for educational
purposes it's within our
rights I'm going to play just the last
minute he used
chat GPT is it to help break down the
scientific
terminology and then look what it said
at the end I'm not gonna play the entire
clip in essence here is the kicker in
essence if the Shroud were truly only
700 years old it would need to have been
stored in one of the hottest regions on
Earth which doesn't align with its known
history this discrepancy further
supports the researchers conclusion that
the Shroud is much likely older closer
to 2 years based on its preservation
condition and the X-ray analysis that's
chat GPT is it called chat GPT is saying
this that the condition of the Shroud
shows that it cannot be only 700 years
old but it actually agrees with the
recent discovery that is closer to 2000
chat gbt okay right
there I just sent you link go watch the
clip and watch I haven't watched Michael
noes yet but there you go but now let me
share the
tweets the tweets boom father Kelvin
Robinson 20 hours
ago a good news day if you'll pardon the
pun a good news day if you'll pardon the
pun here it is this is is on my Twitter
I reposted this all right do you see it
let me post it on the screen Focus
everyone further scientific proof that
the Shroud of Turin is the actual burial
shroud used to wrap the crucified Body
of Christ the Shroud that gave us the
most accurate depiction of the Holy face
of
Jesus there it goes so that's father
Calvin Robinson I reposted it now the
other one let's go back here so this is
my post I also retweeted
s
Jose
S the latest scientific
Revelation reveals that the sh turn was
first made around 2,000 years ago
coinciding with the time when Jesus was
said to be alive and ultimately
crucified suggesting that the barel
cloth bearing the imprint of Jesus
authentic this is actually the image
left by a radiation blast this actually
what the figure looks
like it's amazing we don't have the
technology today to duplicate that image
on a
cloth and yet somehow this
happened somehow it
happened somehow this image just
happened to be
there all right right our Lord lives
with or without the Shroud he's alive
he's risen but what a blessing that God
is giving you the Shroud preserve to
silence naysayers because there's even a
Jewish expert on the Shroud his
name passes Me by I forget his name he
said he goes I'm a Jew I'm not a
Christian he goes there's no way that
this image could have just been
fabricated he goes there's no
explanation he goes I'm a Jew I'm not a
Christian
right he said that I saw him interviewed
in he's he goes look I'm a Jew he says
it he goes I'm not a Christian he goes
that that image that cannot be forged he
goes even with our technology he didn't
know what to
say
yep I'm not exaggerating guys this is a
fact I've always believed a shoud
meaning that I
it's miraculous and I go wow this is the
shot of Our Lord I don't have no problem
with it but with or without it Jesus is
Alive with or without the Sha Jesus is
risen he's alive I don't need the show
Sha to convince me Jesus is alive he's
risen he's Lord but this is such a
blessing from the Lord to silence the
atheist and agnostic what are you
waiting
for right Focus everyone right
yep there it goes so Cameron berui is
going to interview an expert on the
recent study that came out right there
let me see if I can find actual and this
they only saw right in x-ray Imaging in
other words you see a faint figure on
the
Shroud but it was only through extra
Imaging that they could see a full right
full orb what do they call it x-ray
likeness of the body
right here let's
see this is what our Lord would look
like this is his face from me see this
is actually the imprint you see it see
the
imprint see it guys right there this is
what you see you say h but then you put
an x-ray and boom look at this image
that's an actual image this is the
image do that means our Lord looks like
this this is how our Lord looks
you see that that's how our Lord
looks if we go by the image this is how
he looks and you remember Howard storm
in his out of body experience I not out
of his near-death experience who died
The Atheist he goes when he saw Jesus in
his near-death experience he goes he
looked like this face from the Shroud he
said it I played the clip a couple days
ago that's what he said so here's what
the image looks like but when you put it
under x-ray this is what it looks like
look see that are you Blown Away look
it's what it looks
like ultraviolet light how how's this
possible because it's the blast of light
the Divine Light of our Lord Jesus as he
entered his body and then he left an
image of his body from that light blast
as he entered his body
see you see that this is it guys you
guys are not aware of these images it's
like some of you are shocked are you
kidding me I thought you guys knew about
this here are the images look this is
what it would look like see boom there
it is right here that's ultraviolet
light they they saw this under x-ray but
if you just saw the cloth this is all
you're seeing see it's what you're
seeing they have to put under x-ray to
see so that means our Lord's face this
is how he looked like if we go by the
image this is how our Lord
looks this is how he looks as a
man is doesn't it move in your
heart he's in that glorified physical
body he's still a man and he took that
Flesh and Blood and Bones from the
Virgin the Blessed
Mother right there you go see it
so let's look at it again this is what
it looks like under
x-ray boom here and
here here and here and if you actually
go and read the details it says one side
of his face on one side of his face it's
like his beard was pulled out and from
his back you can see marks left from
what seemed to be whipping he was
whipped it's all in the in the image I'm
not lying go watch go read the reports
and they're still going to tell me that
it's not our Lord and even here what
you're seeing here signifies that there
were cuts on his head from the crown of
thorns this what you're seeing here
these here signifying there were cuts on
his head the crown of thorns no no no
it's not the that's it's all fake yeah
yeah it's fake it's fake guys it's fake
fake brother it's
fake so there you go right Lord is alive
you're blessed that you have been raised
in Christian homes but don't take that
for granted because the more blessing
the greater your judgment pray for those
who do not
know right